[Musique]
nous sommes tous en mesure comme
investiture comme journée on ne pouvait
pas demander mieux
ce soir on en sait un peu plus sur ce
pilote qui a réussi cet exploit
oui c'est chic de chelsea seul orgueil
c'est un homme qui travaille depuis une
vingtaine d'années pour usc airways et
auparavant il avait été pilote dans les
forces armées américaines
une opération policière de trois ans qui
aboutit avec l'opération la plus
importante au monde
une opération qui réflète le problème de
criminalité que constituent les angels
au québec et 156 personnes qui sont
visés dans l'opération il y en a cent
dix sept qui sont accusés d' au moins un
meurtre
les accusations sont tombées dans le
drame familial de piedmont dans les
laurentides
le docteur guy turcotte a été accusé du
meurtre prémédité de ses deux enfants de
trois et cinq ans les quatre femmes
retrouvées mortes dans une voiture au
fond d'un canal le mois dernier à
kingston ont bel et bien été assassiné
et des accusations de meurtre prémédité
ont été déposées contre trois personnes
qu'il connaissait très bien des membres
de leur famille
l'histoire il faut dire a pris une
tournure tragique une fin d'année la
nouvelle souche de la grippe a h1n1 se
propage de façon soutenue dans plus
d'une région du monde avec plus de 28000
cas dans 74 pays
on pensait battre de vitesse la grippe a
h1n1 c'est plutôt elle qui gagne du
terrain
[Musique]
j'ai tué ma mère a raflé tout ce qu'ils
pouvaient à la quinzaine des
réalisateurs
ça a été une bonne année pour le cinéma
québécois à cannes
[Musique]
oh